[Music]
it's your health
so you should be able to take care of it
your way because you know vest here it
oh crap this is Steven kryder's Channel
no skip skip the ad skip the ad skip the
ad we don't want to pay for this D
monetize do you monetize skip the ad
[Music]
yeah personally if I see that yellow
bastard on the road I'm cutting a wide
Slough
there's no peripheral vision okay what I
mean there's a blonde [ __ ] here okay
little blind spot back there and that's
why there was a recall now I can't warn
you enough the first time you draw a
profit you could see a resulting
explosion in growth in the company
because our business is easily scalable
you need to be prepared to handle it let
me show you the profit margins I think
he'll be pretty excited about him cover
her head blocks don't work big surprise
their blocks never work not on me
yeah Navy Navy those Redskins are savage
they're absolutely set you have to try
them please
hey watch that brown piece of crap with
the weed whacker so many of them see the
other side of the fence
hey no [ __ ] in here what sorry
[Music]
damn [ __ ] it's always causing problems
all right now fun's over get out of
there whoops oh hey you know you can
subscribe to this channel like clicking
the subscribe button below let me watch
one of these videos playing next to me
aren't gonna Lanos counter comm to see
more videos and articles I got work to
do